The International Space Station contributed
data to science, kept 200 souls alive in space
and, travelled more than 1.5 billion miles.
I think that's pretty good, right?
Let's pack it
in.
Back in 2010, the U.S. considered abandoning
the ISS because of problems with the Russian-made
Soyuz launch vehicles, and political fights
have caused tension since then too.
Russia has just signed on to continue supporting
the International Space Station until 2024
rather than building a Russian-only station.
The International Space Station is an incredible
piece of multinational technology, with former
nemeses coming together to create this football-field-sized
scientific space camp.
But it's expensive, and not getting any younger…
or cheaper.
Plans to build the ISS began in 1993 and it
was completed in 2011.
It's larger than a six bedroom house and weighs
almost a million pounds.
A rotating crew of humans have been sheltered
in the station continuously since 2000, creating
the need for 130-plus launches to build and
supply the place.
The ISS is the single most expensive man-made
object in existence; costing 160 billion dollars
to date.
The U.S. ponied up $100 billion, while Japan,
Canada, Europe and Russia chipped in for the
rest.
That's a huge drawback in a lot of eyes.
Is a 90s-era piece of solar-powered science
technology worth keeping around?
The damn thing was running WindowsXP until
2013!
Now it's on Linux.
In a word, yes.
Though the station is not without its problems
-- according to one NASA Administrator, micrometeoroids
and orbital debris are a concern and the solar
arrays already look like a QUOTE "west Texas
stop sign," but it's the only microgravity
lab we have, and simply by existing it's fostering
political cooperation between 15 countries
and creating jobs the world over.
Building the ISS was really hard, and that
drove people to invent new technology and
create new science.
Since the first crew arrived, the ISS has
hosted more than 200 people who've completed
over 180 spacewalks and 278 research projects
comprising 1000 experiments,; each one teaching
us about our planet or the life upon it, how
it all fits together, how our organisms survive
in space AND how they survive on Earth.
Maintaining and supporting these intrepid
explorers is great for jobs in research, science,
engineering, manufacturing, and even vocational
skills both at home and abroad.
Commercial space alone is said to create nearly
12-thousand jobs a year!
And space-based research led to vaccines for
salmonella and antibiotic resistant bacteria,
new ways to treat cancer, robotic surgical
techniques, and on and on.
According to the NASA Administrator in charge
of the ISS -- they can conceivably keep it
maintained and working until 2024, but after
that it's iffy.
The components should survive until 2028,
NASA says, and the next 10 years will be filled
with even MORE experiments on the humans living
in space, the Earth's climate, and getting
humans into deep space.
If we want to visit asteroids or go to Mars,
we need to learn more about how microgravity
affects humans; what better place than a science
lab in microgravity!?
With NASA and the ISS's help, private space
companies will compete to get up there, driving
down costs to get to low-earth orbit!
Even politicians are on board with keeping
the station flying, recognizing it shows America
QUOTE "continues to hold the high ground."
And over time we're going to see MORE return
on the investment as this is the early stages
of ISS experiments
In 15 years or so, the ISS will likely have
to be de-orbited -- or purposefully crashed
into the ocean.
That will be a sad day.
But for now, the ISS is our last best hope,
for space science.
Switching gears for a moment, we'd like to
thank Domain.com for this episode.
No domain extension will help you tell your
story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting
by using the code DNews when you check out.